sarah jessica parker is remembering her
dear friend willie garson
oh
stannie
you're wearing white
like a virgin touched for the very first
time
the actress took to instagram on friday
to share a touching tribute to her sex
and the city co-star who died on tuesday
following a short illness he was 57.
sarah shared a collection of personal
throwback snaps with her beloved friend
like these
and included some pics from their time
on the hbo series where he played
stanford blatch carrie bradshaw's best
friend oh my god she's fashion roadkill
there's so much heat
around the show right now we kind of
feel we were a little nervous this year
because we felt we were
slightly under the radar before
and
we're certainly not under the radar
anymore which is very exciting so we
can't wait in the post sarah shared her
sadness and reminisced on some of her
favorite memories with him in the
caption she wrote
it's been unbearable sometimes silence
is a statement of the gravity the
anguish the magnitude of the loss of a
30-year friendship a real friendship
that allowed for secrets adventure a
shared professional family truth
concerts road trips meals late night
phone calls a mutual devotion to
parenthood and all of the heartaches and
joy that accompany triumphs
disappointments fear rage and years
spent on sets most especially carrie's
apartment and laughing late into the
night as both stanford and kerry and
willie and sj sarah continued willie i
will miss everything about you and
replay our last moments together i will
re-read every text from your final days
and put to pen our last calls
she concluded her post with the last
thing willie told her great bangles all
around yes godspeed willie garson rest
in peace
come on your opinion means a lot to me
you're my machico kaka mata
so now what you want me to review your
relationship immediately if not sooner
just weeks before his death willy was
spotted on set of the sex and the city
revival and just like that and even
filmed with sarah
and while the actress did not
immediately speak out or post publicly
about his passing she did comment under
co-star chris knoth's post letting fans
know how she was feeling writing thank
you dearest chris i'm not ready yet
we've been friends for about 20 years so
like really close friends so this is
like we but we always say that we'd be
with each other we'd be hanging out
anyway on the on each other's set even
if we weren't on the show together so
it's just an extension of our lives
together just playing these kooky
characters though
[Music]